Everyone ready?
>> Yes.
>> Awesome. Welcome to AI engineer. Thanks
for joining my session.
We are going to be talking about agentic
search for context engineering today.
My name is Leonei. I work at Elastic,
the company behind Elastic Search.
And usually I like to talk about
retrieval on Twitter. Today I'm super
excited to be doing this in person. Uh,
a little bit of housekeeping. If you
want to access the slides and the code
we will be looking at, you can scan the
QR code.
So
let's start with why I'm excited about
search and retrieval and hopefully why
you are excited about it by the end of
this workshop as well.
Who here has built an agent or some form
of it before?
Awesome. Then you've probably then
you're probably not intimidated by this
uh image. You've probably seen some some
alternative to this one before. This is
essentially what context engineering
looks like. So context engineering when
we talk about it is the art or
engineering techniques about how from
all of the possible context sources we
have, how do we actually decide what
goes into the context window so our LLMs
can uh generate the best responses.
Often when we talk about this, we talk
about context curation and we mean this
little this little arrow from context
sources to context window. But we're not
giving this little arrow right there
enough uh credit in my opinion because
what's powering this is the search tool
or search tools that actually decide
what goes from context sources to the
context window. And today we're going to
be looking at the different search tools
we have. So this is my personal hot
take. I like to say that context
engineering is about 80% agentic search
because it's this little box right here.
All right, let's start with a little bit
of history. And when I say history, I
mean the last three years.
Rag. Um when we started with rag the
original idea was that we had a fixed
retrieval pipeline. So the user message
would
usually more or less ver verbatim be
used as a search query to be used
usually as a vector search query to pull
some data or chunks uh from a database
and together with a retrieved context.
it would the user message would go into
the context window and then it would be
fed to the LLM.
Nice.
This has clearly many limitations.
So since this is a fixed pipeline
whether or not you actually need any
context, you're still retrieving
additional information and in the worst
case that can actually confuse your LLM.
Right?
On the other hand, if you're only
retrieving once,
let's say you need some multihop
retrieval, you're asking your LLM
something more complex, then if you're
only retrieving once, maybe the
retrieved chunks um reveal some
information about another search query
you need, then you would actually might
want to have a second round of search,
right? So that's why we then moved on to
aentic rag.
So we replace the fixed pipeline with
now a search tool. So
now the agent can decide by himself by
itself uh whether or not to call the
search tool and retrieve some
information. So we don't have the
problem anymore of do I actually need
any information and when I actually
retrieve information is this even
relevant? Do I need to retrieve more?
Um,
do I actually have to retrieve
something, rewrite the search query? Um,
yeah.
So, we still only have one context
source in this case, one database. Now,
when we look at context engineering, the
context lies in many different places,
right? So, we have context sources in
local files. So when you think about
your coding agent, you probably have
your um coding project in or code files
laying around in your local file system,
maybe you're using um some kind of
working memory like a scratch pad. So
you're planning with your um agent what
you want to do. Then you probably have
something like a plan MD file.
When you have agent skills, you also
have them usually in a local folder
somewhere. We still have databases
because many enterprises have their data
stored in databases.
Um, we have the web as another context
source. And I know this is a super
controversial uh image here because I
did not commit to having the long-term
memory in the local file system or the
database. This is I think a currently a
very big discussion. We can get into
this in the Q&A if you like. But we also
have long-term memory as another context
source. Right?
So how do we actually retrieve context
from these? Usually we have a set of um
let's say context source native search
tools. So for the local files you
usually have something like um a search
files um tool. For skills you usually
have a skill loading tool. When you
think about databases,
we have a little bit more custom tools.
So, um something like a semantic search
tool. Maybe you also have something more
um general purpose like a tool that lets
you execute entire search queries
against a database like SQL for example.
For web you have web search tools and
for memory you have something like a
dedicated memory tool.
If that's not overwhelming enough, we
now also have something called a shell
tool. Um, Langchain calls it shell tool.
Anthropic calls it the bash tool. If
you've experienced uh if you've played
around with open cloud, it's called the
exec tool. But what all of these tools
do is they let your agent run commands
in the terminal. And that actually makes
them super uh versatile because now you
can let your agent um use CLIs to
navigate your um and explore your local
files. So you can just run ls and grab
to find data in your local file system.
If your database has a custom CLI, you
can actually let the agent also use the
shell tool um and interact with the
database.
You could also let your agent write an
entire search entire script from scratch
like connect to your database, run a
search query.
Um, if your database is exposed via
HTTPS, you can just run a curl command,
interact with the database through the
shell tool. Speaking of curl commands,
you can also um do web searches if you
like. So this shell tool is super
versatile, right? So the question and
the topic of today is
what search tool do we actually need? Do
we only need a s a shell tool? Do I need
all of these?
And if you take home only one thing from
today is that doing good search is
incredibly difficult and that's why we
have many different techniques to do
search. Right? We have vector search, we
have keyword search, even in vector
search, we have dense embeddings, sparse
embeddings, multi vector embeddings.
Then we have many different indexing
techniques. So
depending on what kind of search
requirements and latency requirements
you have,
you will need to curate your own stack
of search tools. Right?
So today we're going to be looking at a
few of these. Unfortunately, we only
have one hour, so I cannot show you all
of them. Um,
before we get into some code, I want to
um give you a few fundamentals um of
building good search tools because
agentic search at the surface level
seems very straightforward.
The user makes a request. The agent
calls the right tool with the right
parameters.
I see someone laughing. Um, the
retrieval tool gives you the tool
response and then your agent uh responds
to you with the correct answer.
At Elastic, we help a lot of internal
and external teams build uh agents based
to interact with elastic search data.
And the reality is that this can break
in many different ways. I'm just going
to show you three um today. So the first
is the agent doesn't call any tool. So
this means the agent decides I actually
can answer this question based on my
parametric knowledge. I don't need to
use any um context retrieval tool. And
the other problem is that the agent
calls the wrong tool. I was recently
talking to a colleague of mine was
asking him what was your the most
challenging aspect of your project and
he was like you won't believe it but it
was really difficult to get the agent to
actually not call the web search tool
but call the database search tool
right
and then depending on how complex your
parameters are for your search tools it
can also be quite challenging to get
your agent to generate the right um
search parameters, right?
There's many more failure cases, but
we're going to limit this to to these
three today. So,
I personally hate this slide because I
feel like everyone in this room probably
knows um that the tool description is
the most important aspect, but anytime I
see a tool description, it's like the
least effort, one sentence, and then
you're wondering why your agent isn't
calling the right tool. So, arguably,
this is a very long tool description.
I'm not saying you have to write it like
this. I'm just saying if you just start
with a core purpose, if it works fine,
great. But if you add more parameters or
more tools and your agent is starting to
struggle with calling the right uh tool,
then maybe add some trigger condition.
When should this tool be used? When
should this tool not be used? Especially
if you have multiple tools. Um, adding
something like relationships is super
important, like first call this agent
skill before you actually call this tool
or get some confirmation before you call
this tool.
If you have the perfect tool description
and your agent still doesn't call the
right tool, then reinforce it in the
agent system prompt. That should
actually um help out in most cases.
Then I want to quickly touch on some on
the parameter complexity.
If you have a search tool that's just
very simple in in the sense that
something like get customer by ID, it
should be fairly straightforward for the
agent to generate an ID parameter given
that it's a valid ID. Um same for if
you're doing a semantic search, right?
generating some valid string should be
shouldn't cause any any issues. But
let's say if you want to have a semantic
search tool and instead of just giving
um a topic, you now also want to give it
some filter conditions, maybe you want
to define the top K. Then you start to
have more parameters, right? This isn't
very complex here, but the longer the
list of parameters you have, the more
difficult um it's going to get for the
agent to generate the right ones.
And I think a very complex one for an
agent is to when you have something
that's more general purpose like letting
the agent um execute um entire search
queries against a database. So here I
have ESQL which is the elastic search
query language could be could be SQL as
well. So letting the agent write an
entire SQL query from scratch can be
quite challenging. Most are pretty good,
but um some aren't. So just keep in mind
um let's say the the complexity of the
parameter also is kind of a failure mode
and you can you might need to help the
agent out with um a few of these if the
they are more complex.
Good. Let's look at some code.
Okay,
so
quick show of hands. Who here has built
some sort of agentic rag, agentic surge
before?
Okay, about half. That's good. Um,
so we're going to be looking at three
things. Uh, I'm going to give you a
quick recap or intro to the very vanilla
agentic search demo.
And then I'm going to show you how easy
it is to break this usual demo. And then
we're replacing the semantic search tool
with something more general purpose. So
we're letting the agent write an entire
search query from scratch.
And for these two examples, we will be
using um a local elastic search cluster
as a context source. And then for the
third part, I'm switching gears and I'm
going to be showing you how search over
local file system works um with the bash
tool. And then I'm also going to show
the shell tool. And then I'm also going
to show you um some limitations of the
shell tool and how you can expand it
with custom CLIs.
All right. The example that we'll be
doing today is I have the conference
session data of this conference here.
And let me let me start show you this
one. So just a quick recap.
We have elastic search database and
we're going to be writing a semantic
search
um search tool. And for in the database
I have the conference session
um already chunked. You probably already
know how to chunk and store data in a
database. So we're skipping this part.
This is not the important aspect.
So, what do we need for an agent, an
LLM? Oh, sorry.
We're going to be using lang chain for
this um session just because it wraps a
lot of the complexity and uh I don't
like it lets us concentrate on the high
level concepts. also has some nice
built-in features like uh the shell tool
is built in and it has some uh code
samples for skill loading tools which we
will be looking at later.
Okay, switching back. I'm using GPT 5.4
Nano for this demo.
Then we're defining a very simple system
prompt. So the usual you are a search
agent tasked with answering questions.
Um you have access to different context
retrieval tools and before answering a
question oops decide whether or not you
need to retrieve additional context
to help the agent a little bit I have
some information about how the data is
um structured in elastic search. So here
we have a text field. It's comprised of
the title of each session and the
description of each session and the text
field is what actually gets embedded um
as the vector embeddings for semantic
search and then I also have some
metadata fields. So for example the day,
the time, the room, um the speaker's
name. So since the metadata is not
embedded, I can only run um filters over
them but not any semantic search just
for your information.
Okay,
now the interesting part let's build a
semantic search tool. So how that works
in lang chain is I have to first define
an embedding model. In this case I'm
using the new genome embeddings v5
model.
Um this is used to embed the search
queries at query time and the embedding
model I'm putting in with putting it
into my um elastic search store together
with the elastic data to create a vector
store and then
I can create a search tool. So in this
case I have all I have to do is I call
the similarity search method. It takes
in a search query and in this case I'm
setting the limit or the top K to three.
This is a little bit of foreshadowing
because I'm limiting the capabilities of
this tool to just returning three search
results. Right?
What's nice in Langchain as well is that
when you use the tool decorator up here,
it lets you convert any Python function
into a search tool uh sorry into an
agent tool.
So by default, it takes the
um functions u Python functions name as
the tool name and the dock string down
here is going to uh convert going to get
converted into the tool description. You
can see I'm breaking my own rule by
having a very short tool description
here. Why this works is because I only
have one search tool here, right? So you
will see I'm adding a few things later
on, but it's not going to get very
descriptive in this demo here.
So now we can um run a test and test it
for a search query of regulatory
constraints. And you can see it finds a
talk by my friend B on engineering AI
systems under server constraints and it
also finds some more talks. One by TAS
and one by Pedro.
All right, let's plug it in.
So we're plugging in the LM, the system
prompt, and the search tool. I'm leaving
out memory. Obviously, this would be
another core component of an agent. In
this case, I'm leaving it out to keep it
kind of concise.
Now I can
uh run a simple question like which
sessions discuss regulatory constraints
in AI systems.
And you can see the agent first uh calls
my semantic search tool. It wrote a
quite extensive
search query in my opinion, but it
works. Um, it finds the right talk by
Bili.
Then it decided that that apparently
wasn't enough. So, it rewrote the search
query. Uh, but decided but got the very
similar search results back. So after
that it decided that sorry it decided
that it's now able to um respond with
the right talks.
This is where most agentic search demos
fail. But this is very brittle. Does
anyone have an idea how we can break
this?
Yes, that's a good idea.
Anything else?
Asking it something that's not in the
database would be something great. What
about asking it um something where
semantic search actually falls short?
Maybe something where we want to look
for a keyword, a specific keyword.
um also doing something like filtering
because we're in this search tool we
don't have any filters implemented right
so
my
my choice of search query is which
sessions should I visit to learn more
about GEA
I'm not even sure like I've heard people
talk about Ga I'm not even sure if I'm
pronouncing it correctly sorry that's
why I need to definitely
attend this session.
So what you can see is the agent now
calls the search semantic search tool
and this time it's looking for GPA. So
far so good
but now you can see it's actually
returning a talk for um deep minds Gemma
models. I guess from token from a
tokenization perspective it could be
similar to GDPA or JPA I don't know then
it returns something on harness
engineering not sure if that's
necessarily related and then a third one
I clearly none of these are related to
GPA
spoiler alert I know there's a talk
about GPA or JPA again I think it's
right after this one So
we can see the search tool we just
created. It's not very useful or at
least useful only for a very narrow
scope of use cases. Right?
What if we let the agent now write an
entire search query from scratch? Let me
show you how we can do this.
So
we're now replacing the database tool
that we had with an execute query tool.
So we're letting the agent not only take
in a like a search like a topic, but
this time we're giving it an entire
the search tool an entire search query.
And I'm going to show you because this
is quite difficult for an agent. Uh
we're also combining it with a skill
loading tool.
So
doing the same thing. I'm setting up my
LLM.
You've probably noticed I'm switching to
a little bit more powerful model here.
So I'm switching from the GPT 5.4 Nano
to um the mini because I am now
anticipating that writing search queries
is a little bit more difficult. So the
nano is probably not powerful enough.
I'm using the exact same system prompt
as before.
And now I'm creating a general purpose
database query tool.
Since I'm using elastic search, I'm
going to be using the elastic search
query language, which is a pipe query
language for filtering, transforming,
and analyzing data.
It looks something like this. Maybe it
reminds you of SQL. It's a little bit
different. It has different
capabilities. Not important for this
session. Um, but you can see when I
connect to my client and then I use this
query method from the SQL class and run
this query, you can actually see that
there is a session by Samuel which talks
a lot about GPA. You can see here is a
match.
Here's another match.
So let's wrap this into a search tool.
You can see um this time I just use the
the query method again here and the
agent takes in the ESQL query um as a
parameter
and I exchanged the tool description
with something that's said that's called
execute an ESQL query against the
conference schedule index in elastic
search.
notice anything different about how I
wrote this search tool versus the other
one.
This time I added a try except block
here for error handling. Generally
speaking, you should have error
handling. But since I'm anticipating
that writing a good ESQL query or a
valid one is gonna cause more problems
for the the tool, um I don't want the
agent to just fail and then the whole
system to crash. So instead of instead I
return the error response to the agent
so it can kind of self-correct, rewrite
the query.
Generally speaking, super important to
have this, right? So the agent can
self-correct. So when we we can test
this here, this is not important. Uh
then I'm plugging in the LLM, the system
prompt, and my not new search tool into
the agent again. And when I now um ask
it the exact same question as before,
which session should I visit to learn
more about GDPA?
You can see it calls the execute ESQL
query tool and it generates something
that looks like valid ESQL.
I'm not expecting anyone to be very
familiar with ESQL. What's wrong with
this is that
ESQL doesn't use the percentage sign as
a wild card character. And in ESQL, you
would use the asterisk. So in this case,
it's actually looking for percentage
sign, GPA, percentage sign in the data
as an exact match. So that's why it's
actually returning zero search results.
And this is when you're working with
search tools also super important to
think about. Is returning zero search
results
actually a valid response or is it a
failure mode? Right?
Okay.
How could I overcome this? I could
probably write
um a more descriptive tool description,
give it a little bit more help on how to
write better um parameters.
I could re reinforce it in the system
prompt, give it more instructions there.
Or I could use an agent skill because
you need more documentation than just
like a oneliner, right?
So now I'm going to show you how to add
an agent skill.
So in this case
I'm going to be writing my own very
short custom uh agent skill. Quick
question. Who has you used and played
with agent skills before?
Okay, good amount.
So
I'm going to be writing a very short one
here. Um
there is official elastic search agent
skills available if you want to play
around with it. In this case I'm just uh
using my own custom ones. So how that
works is you have the um the skill name
and then also skill description which
gets injected into the system prompt. So
only the uh if you write it in in
markdown it's the I think the front meta
right that gets injected into the system
prompt and then when you need it um more
information on the agent skill is loaded
into the context window right so it's
called something like progressive
disclosure where you kind of add more
information about the skill as you as
needed
so in this case I have some minimal
instructions like here's the basic um
structure of an ESQL query.
Um ESQL uses double quotes for string
literals.
Just some very basic syntax rules. And I
also added some more information about
the wild card pattern so it's not making
this mistake again.
And then as I mentioned, Langchen has
some boilerplate code you can just copy
and reuse for um using agent skills. So
I'm skipping over this. All you have to
know is we have a tool and skill loading
tool and it's get it's getting inject um
sorry it gets combined with a something
called a skill middleware.
Skipping over this because this is not
relevant for our session.
And now
all I have to do is
um add it edit the tool description of
my general purpose search tool. So this
is the exact same tool that I had before
except this time I'm now adding some
relationship to I'm saying always use
elastic the elastic search ESQL skill to
generate the ESQL query before using
this tool because otherwise if the agent
then still uses this tool first without
without um using the agent skill then
that would be a shame. Right,
I'm doing the exact same. So I'm
reinforcing this now in the system
prompt. I'm saying the same thing to use
the um elastic search a agent skill
first before calling the general purpose
search tool. And now I'm plugging it
into the agent again. So this time LLM
system prompt for the skill loading
tool. I have the skill middleware and
then my general purpose ESQL query tool.
And now when I let the um ask when I ask
the agent which session should I visit
to learn more about Ga you can see it f
first loads the skill.
So it actually loads everything that's
kind of in the body part of the skill
into my context window.
And then it generates
this time a very valid SQL with the
asterisk as my percentage as my wild
card characters. And you can see it
actually finds the right session.
And now it tells me that at 10:40, so
after this session, I should be going to
this session to learn more about GPA and
learn how to pronounce it correctly.
Okay,
what's also cool about this is now the
agent can do a lot of things, right? It
can also do aggregations.
So if I ask it something like how many
sessions are on April 8th, you can see
again it loads the um elastic search
ESQL
tool.
Um and then it writes an ESQL query.
Whoops.
Writes an ESQL query that's using a
filter. So it's filtering for April 8th.
And then it also does an aggregation,
some some counting and tells me today
there are 27 sessions.
This is nice because
if I just do a search, let's say I ask
it to tell me which sessions are on
April 8th and it only runs a filtered
search, right? So just imagine it would
give me a list of all 27 sessions that
are today and we let the agent
count how many sessions there are.
That would probably not be so good
because we all know agents or LMS are
notoriously bad at counting things. Um
and also it would um fill up your
context window, right? So by letting the
agent do its own calculation, so letting
like outsourcing the calculation part
into the search tool, it's actually
quite an efficient way to do this,
right?
Any questions so far.
Okay,
let's switch gears. Um,
this is a very prominent topic at the
moment. Maybe you've heard the
discussion about all an agent needs is a
shell tool and a file system.
So, I work at Elastic, but I don't
discriminate. Let's look at file systems
and how to do this because I think it's
a very interesting um topic in general.
So what I did here um I prepared the
data this time in a local file system.
So I have a folder called session data
and in here I have for each type of
session like keynotes and workshops. I
have another folder and in there there's
per session one file looks something
like this. So with a title, some
metadata and the description.
And now um I'm going to show you how you
can use the shell tool with this.
So I'm switching back to the GPT 5.4
nano because LM are just generally good
at um navigating file systems, writing
uh shell commands. So GPT 5.4 nano is
sufficient. In this case,
I define another system prompt. So the
first part of the system prompt is
uh exactly the same as the one we had
before.
And what I'm replacing this time is
instead of explaining how the data is
structured in elastic search, I'm
explaining how the data is structured in
my local file system.
Okay, so
let's use the shell tool. I have to give
you a disclaimer. Using the shell tool
can be risky since giving your agent
access to a terminal
can make it delete files or do other
things you don't want it to do. So
always recommended to uh use it in a
sandbox environment. Also in langun it
doesn't have any safeguards by default.
So please be careful when using this.
But other than that it's very easy to
use. So you can just use uh import the
shell tool and instantiate it here. And
here you can see how you would use it.
So it takes in the commands parameter.
So when I say echo hello world, you can
see down here it actually prints hello
world into my terminal.
And then all you have to do again plug
in the LLM, the system prompt and the
shell tool. And now you can ask it this
exact same thing we had earlier. So are
there any sessions about GPA and you can
say you can see here it's called the
terminal here but it's the it's the
agent calls the uh shell tool and it
actually writes a few commands. So first
it's looking at the folder structure and
then it runs um some grab commands. So
it's looking for GPA in the session data
and I think it's looking for the first
50 entries.
So you can see it saw the um the folder
structure and then it also found the one
session we were talking about earlier.
But since I was only looking at the
first 50 and only found one session, it
decided that it should probably look at
the entire session data. So it finds the
exact same session again. So this time
it decides, okay, then I should probably
look at the contents of this session.
So now it reads the entire file content.
And here you can see the
the session information
um as a tool response.
And then at the end the agent tells me
which session I should visit.
Okay.
Grab works
based on exact matches, right? And um
reg.
And I just want to show you this because
I think it's funny how like surprisingly
good agents are with bash because they
kind of can cheat at semantic search. I
Let me show you this.
So when I ask it which sessions discuss
handling regulatory constraints, this
was our semantic search query from the
beginning. You can see it again looks at
the folder structure and then it the
first command or the first search it
does it's looking for regulate.
It's fair. It's looking for regulation
for regulatory.
I guess that's that's a fair start. But
then it goes ahead and now it just
chains a bunch of synonyms together. So
it's looking for compliance. It's
looking for constraints. It's looking
for GDPR. It's looking for governance.
Yeah, I guess that's fair.
Um, I think it actually finds the it
finds a bunch of sessions. So, it's
like, okay, let me try a bunch of other
synonyms. So, now it's looking again for
uh regulate, compliance, GDPR, PR,
soenity.
Um, I think yeah, the list goes on. It's
just looking at a bunch of different
synonyms and it actually is successful
with this and it finds the session by
building and returns the session
information and then um is able to
respond correctly.
I guess it works. Is that the most
efficient way to do this?
Probably not. I mean just as an example.
So, let's say you you want to search for
something like movies with animal
superheroes or something. Do you really
want to do your agent to search for a
list of all the animals possible? Will
you find all the superhero movies with
animal superheroes?
Probably not. So,
it works.
Is it the best? I let you decide.
So at the moment there's many different
semantic search alternatives to grab. Um
I think there's one by llama index
called sam tools. There's a really cool
one by light on which is called coal
grap based on multi vector embeddings.
Also there's one by our own Gina that's
called Gina Grap. Um, today I'm going to
show you how easy it is to actually um,
use this together with your agent.
So, all you have to do is go ahead and
install the Gina CLI
and then
all all you have to do is tell your
agent that it now has access to this
tool or to the CLI.
So, this is the exact same system prompt
as I had earlier. Now with the
difference that I'm explaining to it um
that it has gen
works how it should use it.
Here are some examples of how you would
use Gina Grap.
Just a disclaimer Gina Grap has many
different modes. You can use it for um
classification. You can use it for
re-ranking. Today I'm just showing you
how to use it for semantic search.
And at the end I'm also explaining to
the agent when it should use grap and
when it should use gina grabs. Just so
it knows for exact matches you probably
still want to use grap. And for um more
semantic search or fuzzy queries use um
gina grap.
And then plugging this in to my agent
again.
And when I now run the exact same
semantic search query we had earlier. So
which oops
which sessions discuss handling
regulatory constraints. You can see the
same behavior. So it calls the terminal
tool. It first explores the folder
structure and then it actually on the
first try is able to correctly use gina
grab. So, it's looking for regulatory
constraints
and boom, it actually finds um the
session by Bill on the first first try.
Finds a few others because it's looking
for 10. Um it says returned top k of 10
and then it's able to answer me
correctly. Nice.
All right. Any questions so far?
Good.
Then I'm switching back.
So we were looking at a bunch of
different tools today. We saw how big
the tool landscape is. Um I showed you a
few of the um search tools we have. Now,
some practical recommendations on when
should you actually use what.
So,
maybe let's start with this. If you're
looking for just one silver bullet tool,
that's probably not the right way to go.
Again, if you're if you think about it,
doing good search is incredibly
difficult. So ideally you want to have
or curate the right set of search tools
for your agents search behaviors
and you want to have a combination of
specialized tools and a combination and
uh general purpose tools. So specialized
tools are something that the agent can
use out of the box. Something with a
very simple parameter,
something where you're not where you
don't need a very powerful LLM. You
know, the agent isn't going to make a
lot of mistakes. The agent can just use
this tool out of the box. So at Elastic,
we like to think about this about of
having a low floor. So this is a concept
from user experience where the agent can
just
you use a tool doesn't make many
mistakes. It's also efficient so it
doesn't have to run your tool multiple
times. You can think about this as the
semantic search tool we had earlier.
Maybe you need to look up customers by
ID a lot of the time. Then having a
specialized tool for that exact
operation would be helpful.
But then you also want to give the agent
a high ceiling. That means
for unexpected queries, for complex
questions, you want the agent to still
be able to handle these questions,
right? And not be have like these
limited uh specialized tools and be
like, I I cannot solve this. So for this
case, something like a shell tool or the
very um general purpose one we had
earlier of a query execution tool would
be very helpful.
But the problem with the query execution
tool or the shell tool you saw earlier
is since it's so general purpose, the
agent sometimes might need more
iteration to iterations to actually get
to the right answer. Right?
So this is my my practical
recommendation of having a balanced set
of search tools um of a low floor and
high ceiling.
This is all nice when you already know
your agents behavior,
but if you don't know your agents query
behavior yet, then I would recommend to
start with a general purpose tool.
Then log your agent's behavior.
Generally speaking, logging your agents
behavior recommended. Um, but if you
notice, maybe your agent is taking
four or five tool calls per question.
That's too many tool calls. Then you
probably that's probably an indicator
that the tool your agent has is too
difficult for it to use. then definitely
look at what the agent's actually trying
to solve, maybe scope out something more
specialized in that case, right?
Also, if you notice specific um query
behaviors, this is what I personally did
with my with my test open claw. I was uh
it has the exec tool and I um started
logging its behavior and obviously I was
playing around with databases. So after
three days I was asking it what kind of
interesting patterns do you see and was
recommending me actually to um implement
some specific uh search tools uh to
interact with the database because it
was out of the box only using the the
exec tool.
All right. Start with general purpose
tools if you don't know your users
behavior yet. Log breaks and app
purposeuilt interfaces.
Yeah, that's that was a lot to take in.
Um,
I'm sure you have lots of questions, so
I'm opening it up for Q&A. And
otherwise, on your way out, don't forget
to grab yourself some stickers. And then
thank you for joining my session.
I think there's a mic coming.
Thank you. Um, so would you say the tool
stack you need is also mostly dependent
on the model you're willing to use. So
if you were using a very good model, it
might be fine using the shell tool or
the search tool, but a very small model
and light agent might need more
specialized tools or
>> Yeah, actually we I think in our
internal testing we noticed that a more
powerful tool actually reduces the error
rate of um for the parameters by I don't
know the numbers exactly but it was a
very big amount where it reduced the
error rate. So having a stronger model
definitely helps
um for the general purpose tools but I
think you cannot expect uh just because
you have a very strong model that
there's going to be no no errors if that
makes sense. Yeah.
>> Thanks for a nice talk. Um I have one
question. Maybe it's slightly off topic
but um so now we are talking about a
gentic rack but it comes with the
drawback of having higher latency
against typical rack. So would you
recommend of having like a second
pathway for simple rack for fast answers
and how would you like
guide the agent to actually choose the
right one because I think it's hard to
say which question should be answered by
a gent or by simple rag.
>> That's a good question.
I I don't think I have a have a good
answer on like on the top of my head
right now. I'm thinking I was maybe
something related. I was asked recently
if you have a rag system, should you
replace it with a gentic rag? And I
guess this is kind of going in the same
direction of when do you actually need a
gentic rag, right?
um
probably for a lot of use cases. I know
rag has been killed many times, but I
think the reality is that rag is still
very effective for many use cases. Um
how would you actually switch between
rag and agentic rag? I'm not sure
because I assume it's again it needs
some kind of almost agentic logic of
switching between them. So
I'm not sure. I'm sorry.
In such cases uh like um when you have
uh the wild card in the GAPA
uh example uh why can't we just um
perform a hybrid tool that maybe search
and replaces uh common wrong uh wild
card symbols coming from SQL with the
correct ones for instance.
>> I'm not sure if I understand your
question correctly. I mean um
there are cases in which uh the agent
does doesn't know the how to write the
uh correct query because maybe he thinks
uh the placeholders uh coming from SQL
um apply to ESQL
but uh so why don't we perform a hybrid
tool that um determine significantly um
uh search and replaces the wrong um
placeholder
the the percentage symbol with the
asterisk.
>> Yeah, actually so the the example I
showed you of using the agent skill
wasn't necessarily the the necessary
solution for it. You can also um add
just some very simple instructions on
for ESQL don't use um the percentage
sign as a wild card character. It
actually works. I tried it when I was
building the the demo. Um but then when
the agent now runs in the next issue,
then you start adding the next piece of
documentation. then you can kind of
start writing the entire ESQL
documentmentation from scratch into your
system prompt. And yes, for the demo
purposes is it would have worked, but
it's probably not how you would do it
necessarily when you're building
something more robust, right? Because if
you just add like little like band-aids
every time you run into an error, then
what happens when you run into the next
edge case? Does that make sense? Yeah.
>> Hi, thank you for the really wonderful
um presentation. I have a question. Uh
in the demo we have walk through the
agentic search with DB curious tool and
also another one with shell tool. Would
you recommend in the practical use we
can also kind of uh use combine both
tool and then we validate the result
from each of tool and then we kind of
add the confidence of the result from
the LM. Would you like recommend doing
this in a practical use?
>> Yes. Yes. That's a great question. Also
again I'm kind of cheating in this demo
right because I'm only showing you one
tool per demo. In reality, you would
have something more like a bunch of
different tools where you then have to
um decide which or the agent has to
decide which tool to use. I think there
was a very interesting blog post by
Versel I believe and they did an
experiment. I think it's called, if you
want to look it up, I think it's called
testing is if bash is all you need is
the title I think of the blog post. And
they actually kind of benchmarked or
tested an agent with a bash tool, an
agent with a just file search tools, I
believe, and an agent with database
tools. And in the end, they also had one
agent with a bash tool and the database
tool. and they noticed that was super
interesting.
Uh for a specific set of queries um
where you have analytical queries,
this is a specific use case. Actually,
the database tool was more effective,
but on the other hand, the file search
tool is very effective as you saw for
just quickly finding things. But the
very interesting aspect was the hybrid
agent with the bash tool and the um
database tool was actually achieving the
highest um like highest accuracy because
it first I believe it was first using
the database tool and then verifying the
results with the shell with the shell
tool and that led the agent to actually
achieve better accuracy. So I think that
was a very interesting way um and
behavior to see in in agents.
>> Thanks for sharing.
>> Um one second question. Um, so if we use
the semantic search tool, I think in
practice you probably would use some
kind of threshold to cut the results to
not get something if there's no answer.
But in the agentic regime, would you
then say, okay, let's put a conservative
threshold such that we don't confuse our
agent or would you say the agent is
smart enough even if we retrieve results
that are not really relevant, it will be
good enough to to to notice that?
>> Yeah, that's a great question actually.
Um, so in the examples you probably saw
some where the agent was returning. I
think in the last genograph example, you
see it's actually returning the top K
results where only the first one is the
actual relevant one. And I think um
because the agent does a little bit of
reasoning over whether the search
results are relevant to the search
query, I think it's much better or
they're much better today at kind of
weeding out what's not relevant. But
then you kind of run into the risk if
you have longer running conversations
that kind of these search results sit in
your context window longterm could have
the problem of confusing your agent long
term. So I think it kind of
it depends on your use case of how
um your like how your agent can handle
like irrelevant search results.
Generally speaking, based on search
results, it can filter out what's
irrelevant.
Uh thank you for the talk. Amazing. Um
are you utilizing sub agents for this
search queries? Because yeah, if we let
them decide to is it relevant to use a
question like yeah it's done in reggas
framework for example for evaluation.
I mean sub agents would help a lot. Do
you have any experience with them?
>> Unfortunately not. I have not played
around with sub aents yet. I can only
tell you that I know for example I
believe in cloud code they're using sub
aents for doing specific search tasks. I
think there was a blog post on how
they're actually using a sub agent to um
answer specific questions about claw
code because it's kind of like a niche
question a user would ask. So in this
case they kind of outsourced um their
expertise to a sub agent. So having a
sub agent for specific niche questions I
think would be interesting but I don't
have too much like experience and
>> Okay. Thanks. Uh can I ask another
question?
>> Sure.
>> Um
damn I forget. Sorry
I try to catch up later.
Um yeah, I kindly off topic but um you
talked about skills and the big benefit
of skills is just have the description
in the uh system prompt and whenever
needed we need to load this the full
skill. Um do you have any recommendation
when and how to clear the system prompt
again? So because we want to keep the
context window small and maybe for a
long um session we might have up to 10
skills full skills in the context and
yeah
>> I'm not sure Joe do you have a better
answer like have an idea.
>> So what we're doing is that we learn the
skills like
but then we
to like offload things. So when the
context
very small
but
um but yeah so like the way that we are
doing it behind the scenes is that we're
we're we're providing like that kind of
progressive disclosure of skills. So
we're providing those um the skill names
and descriptions the location within the
file store and then from the file store
we're loading into the context window
when we need that skill and then we
offload it once it's once it the prog
you know the context window progresses
ahead of time around that. So we have
this kind of more on demand one around
that. And that's the same with our like
compaction like comp of context and
that's what I would advise you to do
like some of the questions do try and
use the file store as much as you can
and have those tools as well like being
able to grap the file store for when you
want to see previous tool results and
then and then use it from that.
Thanks as my colleague Joe from Elastic
as well.
Awesome. If there are no more question,
I will let you guys go into the coffee
break. Again, don't forget to grab
yourself some stickers and happy to
catch up in the halls if anyone's
interested. Thanks so much.